a brutal retaliation for turning fbi
informant a public hit in the middle of
a hobby shop and a gas station
assassination in front of kids strap in
you're about to see the most devastating
deaths on the sopranos
richie abriel was the brother of jackie
april who was head of the dimio crime
family when the series started tony
eventually became the de facto boss when
jackie died although he positioned his
uncle junior as the nominal head richie
was in prison for 10 years when all this
was happening so when he reemerged
things were much different than he
remembered he resented tony as the boss
seeing him as the young guy who had to
buy him dinner and take orders from him
moreover richie made the other mobsters
look like cultured calm gentlemen
violence was his only solution to
virtually everything come here come here
oh come here
another complicating factor was that
richie started dating his old flame
janus soprano tony's older sister the
scheming and power hungry janus would
needle richie about tony urging him to
make a move to take over the family but
what looked like it would become a
deadly power struggle between richie and
tony had a shocking ending after richie
and janice got engaged they got in an
argument as janus defended richie's gay
son little ricky richie nonchalantly
punched her in the face and then started
eating dinner janice responded as such
i'm in no move for you
tony cleaned up after her and put her on
a bus out of town as two of his biggest
headaches canceled each other out richie
died in the season two episode the night
in white saturn armor
sal big [ __ ] bon pinciero was not only
a loyal soldier of tony sopranos he was
also a loyal soldier to tony's father
johnny boy he was a beloved jovial
figure in the crew and a family man with
an even temper indeed he loved his wife
and kids so much that he started to live
outside his means and launched a
sideline of selling heroin he did this
against the advice of jackie april
senior given its risk sure enough big
[ __ ] was caught and arrested facing 30
years in prison he became an informant
for the fbi for a long time he felt
conflicted about informing feeding the
fbi as little as possible a crooked cop
and tony's employee learned that big
[ __ ] was an informant but tony would
not act without total certainty when
another member of his organization who
bore a resemblance was outed big [ __ ]
was seemingly safe for a while but one
big [ __ ] was demoted by tony he was
suddenly more amenable to informing on
him guided by a dream tony found a
pretext to search big pussy's bedroom
and found a wire he then lured his
former best friend onto a boat at sea
where tony paulie and silvio dante shot
after getting him to admit he had
flipped
is that okay tony
did i sit
this happened in the season two episode
fun house it was a stunning death
because he was the biggest protagonist
to die on the show up until that point
jackie jr was living proof that brains
and cunning did not necessarily run in
the family his dad was a beloved and
respected crime boss who was smart
enough to know that his son wasn't cut
out for the family business and
encouraged him to go to college hey
college boy how's school good you know
back in the books
almost dean's list
when jackie april died and richie got
out of prison jackie jr started
gravitating toward mob life even though
he was thick as a brick after richie
died jackie jr seemed to turn his life
around until his mother rosalie started
dating the truly vile ralphs of loreto
jackie jr started dealing drugs just as
he started dating tony's daughter meadow
tony had promised jackie senior that
he'd look after his son but jackie jr
was selling and using drugs and meadow
dumped him when she found out he had
slept with a sex worker i know he's
cheating on me
i could hear it in his voice
jackie jr assembled his own young crew
even dumber than he was and tried to rob
a card game run by one of tony's men he
did it partly because his dad and tony
had done something similar when they
were kids this had helped them make a
name for themselves back in the day of
course it didn't work out quite as well
for jackie and his crew jackie foolishly
shoots the car dealer after realizing
he'd been identified and went into
hiding if you can keep your head while
those around you can't then
after some deliberation tony had vito
spadafor shoot jackie jr in the back of
the head in the season 3 episode army of
one naturally tony blamed the killing on
black drug dealers but meadow knew
better
don't worry though ralph's luck didn't
last forever there was no way the single
most grating character on the show was
going to get away with all of his smart
remarks and excessive violence
he was the ultimate example of how a mob
leader like tony had to weigh business
utility against personal interactions
because ralph was easily his top earner
but no one could stand him ralph's mouth
and temper frequently created problems
his tasteless joke about jenny
sacrimoni's weight nearly caused an
all-out war he coldly killed his
stripper girlfriend tracy he pranked
paulie walnuts mother and nearly gave
her a heart attack his bad influence
helped lead jackie april junior to his
death in short ralph was just the worst
and was killed in the season 4 episode
whoever did this when one of ralph's
sons nearly killed the other
accidentally with an errant and
unsupervised arrow ralph suddenly needed
a lot more money for hospital bills
while he felt horrible about his son
that didn't stop him from burning down
the stable that contained a racehorse
co-owned by tony and him when tony
talked to him about it and ralph more or
less confessed to it tony went into a
rage what followed was the essence of
the sopranos in many ways an awkward
ugly visceral fight that was
uncomfortable to watch tony eventually
strangled ralph and slammed his head
into the floor to kill him he and
christopher then spent a long time
chopping him up and disposing of the
body
the death of tony blandetto was one of
the more painful and significant in the
history of the sopranos known as little
tony he and tony soprano were cousins
and grew up together tony b went to
prison but emerged a changed man he
intended to go straight and take up a
surprising trade i'm gonna be a licensed
massage therapist
for a while he did just that even
turning down a job with his cousin tony
in the organization when working with an
outsider started to go sour tony b went
back to crime the problem was that even
though he was dealt back in he didn't
advance as quickly as he wanted he took
a contract killing job from associates
of little carmine shooting an associate
to fill leotardo tony b denied taking
the job but things escalated as phil
avenged that killing and tony be
retaliated by killing phil's brother
billy and wounding phil phil was out for
blood but tony soprano was reluctant to
give tony b up that was partly out of
love but mostly out of guilt as he had
lied about what happened the night tony
b was arrested saying he was jumped
ironically tony realized this in a
therapy session and later confessed it
to tony b after dealing with a near
revolt from his own men tony took
matters into his own heads cleanly
killing tony b so that phil wouldn't
torture him before executing him in the
season 5 episode all due respect
sometimes the illusion of freedom is far
worse than being resigned to a lifetime
of servitude such was the case for
eugene ponticorovo a loyal soldier of
tony soprano who was given a
life-changing amount of money by a dead
aunt it was so much money that he hoped
to move to florida with his wife and
kids and retire from mob life he gave
tony a taste of the cash and a variety
of gifts in an attempt to buy himself
out of servitude at the same time it was
revealed that he was also an informant
for the fbi they wanted him to stay
especially since another of their
informants had just died the problem was
that eugene had counted his chickens
before they hatched and assured his wife
that tony would say yes even after he
was forced to help christopher
moltesanti with a hit in order to curry
tony's favor the answer was still no the
verdict delivered second hand through
tony's right-hand man silvio that's a
no-go what can't be accommodated you're
part of the team
but i just did that thing that's not my
department
his wife was furious and wouldn't accept
any kind of compromise with seemingly no
way out eugene shockingly went into his
basement and hanged himself this took
place in the season 6 episode members
only the scene as shot was long and
lingering as a way of reminding the
viewer just how desperate things had
become for eugene
veda spadafor was the quintessential
sopranos character deeply flawed morally
yet sympathetic in some ways fido was
one of tony's top earners a family man
and a loyal soldier he carried out the
hit on jackie april jr for example vito
also had a secret he was a closeted gay
man who sought out public hookups and
frequented gay bars for the mob being
gay was almost worse than being an fbi
informant in this particular time period
at least vito was spotted in a gay bar
in full leather regalia by an associate
of tony's no one quite wanted to believe
it and tony revealed he honestly didn't
care what people did behind closed doors
however phil leotardo was out for blood
as vita was married to his cousin and
phil was a rampaging homophobe when tony
sent two of his men to bring vito in for
a little chat vito fled to new hampshire
in a small tourist town vito found
refuge pretending to be a sports writer
he struck up a romance with a cook
here's your johnny cakes
i gotta warn you they're addictive
though he relished the freedom to be
himself he missed his family and the
excitement of the mob lifestyle plus he
hated actually having to work for a
living as handyman so he went back to
new jersey phil ambushed vito and had
his men brutally beat him to death in
the season 6 episode cold stones phil's
sheer exuberance in watching vito die
made this one of the show's most
disturbing death scenes
john johnny sack sacrimoni was the head
of new york's lupertotsy crime family
and usually a close ally of tony soprano
they weren't exactly friends but both
were usually the cooler heads that
prevailed for the sake of peace and
expanding business at one point he
nearly started a war out of sheer
outrage when a member of tony's crime
family insulted his beloved but
overweight wife ginny with a tasteless
fat joke that conflict was averted but
another one started when tony's cousin
tony blandetto killed the brother of
phil leotardo one of johnny sack's capos
just when that crisis was diffused
johnny was arrested by the fbi who had
reams of evidence on him thanks to an
informant johnny didn't flip and become
a rat himself but he did plead guilty
and perform an allocution which included
admitting that the mafia existed a huge
breach of kosonostra protocol he did
this in part to get a reduced sentence
so he could get out and still be young
enough to enjoy his life and his
grandchildren but fate had a way of
playing a cruel trick on him years of
smoking led to advanced lung cancer and
he died in a prison hospital the mundane
nature of his death made it all the more
relatable as it reaffirmed that mob
figures weren't invincible he died in
the season 6 episode stage 5.
john look at me baby
the tragic tale of adriano lacerva was
the saddest ending for any character on
the show the niece of richie and jackie
april she was familiar with the
temptations and perils of mob life and
certainly didn't shy away from it in
dating christopher maltsenty and
eventually becoming engaged to him she
clearly saw herself eventually living a
life of luxury indeed when chris gave
her a nightclub to manage it was all
that adriana had wanted adriana had the
misfortune of being targeted by the fbi
as a potential way of getting
incriminating information on tony
soprano they sent agent deborah cicerone
undercover to befriend her and before
long adriana was blabbing her whole life
story to her when christopher hit on
deborah and adriana blamed her they
brought adriana in and told her that
either she was going to jail or she was
going to become an informant adriana
reluctantly flipped but said as little
as possible until a murder happened in
her club that she tried to cover up the
fbi wanted her to wear a wire and said
she and christopher could go into
witness protection when she told
christopher he in turn told tony who
then made up a story about chris being
in an accident and had silvio pick
adriana up silvio took her to the woods
and executed her
come on no no
chris chose tony over her or more
precisely he chose mob life adriana was
killed in the season 5 episode long term
parking
christopher moltesanti was technically
tony soprano's cousin but due to their
age difference he referred to him as his
nephew he was one of the people closest
to tony and a loyal soldier
unfortunately for everyone christopher
was also an addict who drifted in and
out of heroin and alcohol dependency
when tony needed someone to do dirty
work like disposing of ralph separato's
body he called christopher he literally
knew where all the bodies were buried
conversely tony was there for
christopher as well he urged him to get
clean in an intervention and later had
christopher's fiance adriana killed when
that had to be done what led to his
death an impaired christopher was
driving tony on a highway and drifted
into the wrong lane he swerved and they
flipped multiple times into a ditch
christopher wasn't wearing a seatbelt
and was coughing up blood but still
alive however he begged tony for help
telling him he'd never pass a drug test
when tony saw the baby seat for
christopher's infant daughter pierced by
a huge branch he realized that
christopher was way too much of a loose
cannon as an addict he was also
vulnerable to being flipped by the fence
instead of helping christopher tony
pinched his nephew's nose and suffocated
him as with many of the show's
characters it was a pathetic ending for
a cruel sad life even the show's major
characters weren't immune he died in the
season six episode kennedy and heidi how
are you doing
stuff
yeah
bobby baccalieri was the closest thing
to a decent human being on the sopranos
you're not going to jump me
what
i'm hoping here i'll have to king you
ridiculed for his weight and gentle
manner he nonetheless was highly loyal
to junior soprano and then tony when he
became part of his crew bobby was born
into this life thanks to his dad who was
a ruthless hitman bobby managed to avoid
killing for most of his career making
money as a loan shark he didn't live the
kind of fast-paced lifestyle of the rest
of the crew and didn't even keep a
mistress that changed after he married
tony's sister janice bobby's longtime
wife karen died in a car accident and
janice insinuated her way into his life
and that of his kids when tony and his
wife carmelo went on a cabin excursion
with bobby and janice bobby got in a
fistfight with tony and juan defending
his wife's honor tony resented losing
and gave bobby his first hit assignment
much to bobby chagrin when phil leotardo
decided to wipe out tony's mob bobby was
one of the targets in the season six
episode the blue comet poor bobby was
shot down in a public hit in a model
railroad store it was a sad end for a
man who probably would have had a
different career if he hadn't been born
into this one
phil leotardo was another mobster who
was released from prison during the
course of the show he served a 20-year
sentence and went back to work for the
libertatsi family and johnny sack
leotardo had a veneer of respectability
but he was a brutal killer and sickening
homophobe he nearly started wars with
tony soprano several times over various
offenses related to business and his men
getting killed or beaten that included
him wanting to kill tony's cousin tony
blandetto and one of tony's soldiers
vito spadafor
after yet another conflict leotardo got
the go-ahead to kill tony and his top
men after tony evaded him he negotiated
with leotardo's disgruntled captains and
got their permission to kill him
leotardo was the last on-screen death of
the entire series occurring during the
series finale made in america tony's men
spotted him at a gas station and shot
him with the car running and his
grandkids sitting in the back seat
what made the scene particularly
horrifying was that the car lurched
forward and crushed leotardo's skull
rendering him unrecognizable check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]